alhamdulillah we are in contract to
purchase this 35 000 square foot
facility to make it the dean center and
in it there will be a masjid inshallah
the last and final messenger sent to
mankind the prophet peace and blessings
be upon him said that the one who helps
build a masjid for allah allah will
build for them a house in jannah get the
tremendous rewards and donate right now
to help purchase this property may god
almighty allah reward all of you
[Music]
who he was right what would you say to
him is one proof
that he can look at to to confirm that
islam is the quran is not a man-made
book and islam is not a man-made
religion is indeed from the divine
being an expert in the quran
well um
lots can be said um i'd start off by my
own journey to share can you hear him a
couple of things can you hear them
andrew yeah okay
nice talking to you uh i think that i
what i like to do uh when i meet with
audiences
uh professors of other faiths and you
know intellectuals anybody uh is that i
like to invite them to explore the quran
you know intellectually and critically
that's an invitation that the quran
gives
it's interesting that people perceive
religion as something that you have to
be indoctrinated into
and you have to follow it as the
dictates are and you don't have to
actually critically ask any questions or
think and contemplate and the quran
is kind of unique in the way that it
presents its message because it's
constantly saying don't you then think
don't you contemplate haven't you asked
questions this is a book for those who
seek to ask to have answers
it's not actually asking you to shut
your brain off and accept what it's
saying it's actually asking you to
contemplate its message so it stands
really unique in that sense
my own you know since it offered that
invitation to me i didn't come to the
quran first as someone who believes in
it i
wanted to figure this thing out and you
know trying to make sense of it
and
many of the things that i struggled with
in philosophy when i was a student of
philosophy
they started getting unraveled as i was
getting deeper and deeper in my study of
the quran it just started kind of
untying a lot of those knots and it's
also remarkable that
some of the biggest addictions that
people suffer from
every one of them is targeted one after
the other in the quran
right some of the things that plague
humanity more like gambling for example
alcohol for example intoxication for
example like
each of these things is targeted and you
think
it's not just solving a muslim problem
it's solving a human problem
it's solving a societal problem and
solving a global problem by targeting
these each each of these specific things
um the other thing that i would that
really fascinated me i ended up writing
a book on it ended up getting taught
around the world alhamdulillah it's even
being used
in one of the islamic studies courses at
harvard now
is divine speech it's a book i dedicated
along with my student to why is this why
is this book why am i believing that
it's divine what's making me think this
and i wrote it for a non-muslim audience
actually
it's a little bit academic but the point
of it was there are there are elements
to this book
and the way that it's structured that if
you first if you went to the library or
you got on amazon and bought yourself a
translation of the quran you started
reading it
you think the subject is kind of going
all over the place right it's it's not
staying on the same subject right it's
saying some profound things but the
organization seems unlike anything i've
ever read
and that was one of the things that
baffled me at first like why is it
organized in this way and so i one of
the areas of my study became the
organization of the quran why is it
organized in this way why is god talking
in this disarray and what i discovered
was something absolutely breathtaking
that it's it's got a symmetrical
structure
that you'll have a chapter for example
that's hundreds of verses like backlash
286 verses it's an oral tradition so it
wasn't written first it was recited and
pronounced and memorized in that way
amounts to about 50 pages in arabic
right
but if you study the subject matter
the the the nine subjects that are
occurring in this long
50 page discourse
are like subject one is directly tied to
subject nine and two to eight and three
to seven and four to six and five right
center in the middle like there's an
incredible three-dimensional structure
to the way the arguments being presented
human beings we think linear right i'm
going to make point a then i'm going to
make point b then i'm going to make
point c that's how i organize my
thoughts
and unless you write something down and
say you know what i'm going to do this
and just for fun i'm going to do abc and
then go cba
right even doing that in six sentences
is hard for me as i'm sitting here
talking to you because my brain isn't
wired that way but this thousand you
know a millennium and a half old
tradition has got multiple surahs and
multiple chapters
where this kind of a structure is
demonstrated over and over again and
other kinds of structures are like this
is not possible for a human being to do
linguistically it's not possible i'm a
student of linguistics it's just not
possible these kinds of structures this
kind of organization that that's one of
the things i wrote about in the book and
i started ended up teaching courses on
this stuff
um
but for just
just take a step back level my
invitation to anybody is put your
preconceived notions aside take what you
may have heard about islam what you may
have thought about it from your own
faith traditions point of view put all
of that aside and you know i wouldn't
even invite somebody to read the quran
to accept islam read the quran
neutrally and get a first
you know an unbiased impression
and i would think it's really difficult
to not walk away truly being moved
by what you're what you're being exposed
to truly being hit by what you're
exposed to
uh the final thing i'll say is there is
a huge
tragedy in the world today that even
most muslims aren't as aware of the
quran as they should be
right so muslims don't become a really
good representation of the contents of
the book right so even disconnecting
yourself from the muslim bias i'm just
going to read this for myself
with no other influences as much as
possible at the end of the day human
beings can
are going to have some bias or the other
but as much as i can consciously be
disconnected from bias and give it a
shot
and read it i think that that would be
my invitation to anybody
andrew any question any uh final
question anything you'd like to ask him
while he's here what happened was
because we got delayed with the program
he next guest was coming in so i'm with
you
but this is amazing you can look him up
actually online
and you'll see a ton of his videos
i'm going to i'm going to read that book
as well because it was really
interesting what you were saying it was
really interesting after the show i'd
like to send you a copy as a gift and
also your invitation is exactly the way
i would have done it anyway i would have
read it i'm going to read it i've yet to
read the quran but it's certainly
something i'm going to do i'm going to
read it without a preconceived notion
without a preconceived idea and i think
that's the best way to do things because
you're right there's too much bias in
the world but um from from what i know i
think we just talked about for the last
hour from what i know i have absolute
respect for the religion and respect for
the faith and i've been very
very blessed to be on the show so thank
you very much for having me i appreciate
it thank you i cannot leave without
giving you a gift if you're not yet
muslim and you're tuning in to see what
these muslims are talking about and you
like a free copy of the quran go and
visit the show.com we'll take care of
the postage and everything and get it
delivered to you and if you still have
some questions
about islam call us at
1-800-662-4752 we'll see you next time
until then peace be with you assalamu
alaikum and if you liked this episode of
the deen show
like this video
share this video
far and wide and support us on our
patreon page so we can continue this
work
thank you for tuning in peace be with
you assalamu alaikum